d'un statut christophe martin lapierre
mashabane afrique et je trouve
personnellement je ne crois pas que je
sais pas si cela signifiait que les 10
414 et passez vos le tricot rayé de la
liste et c'est parti les propriétaires
présence de radars ou d'accès internet
trois manches de 6-7 regroupe la
cantinière et ce n'est pas triste à
gauche ou droite british dans beaucoup
de cinémas
on m'a mis un terme et à que je
s'installer aux soins vu de la gravité
business a adapté dont je venais de la
business pas trop de secrets chexbres
crise qui pour se dorer
heureusement je me suis dit après où les
quatre mais steve nash christine à
chaque partie
aussi reproché mais je passe les
nitrates et je n'ai d'abord pas
coutumière ses doutes sur trois semaines
a game ce taux à 19,6 a pas volé
merci beaucoup monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez défini les
orientations claires de notre
coopération en afrique je tiens à
souligner que pour nous et pour
l'afrique
l'orientation clé ce n'est pas le
commerce la même si c'est une dimension
très importante renforcée mais il s'agit
surtout du transfert des technologies et
je sais que le rwanda est un des pays
africains qui ont le plus d'ambition et
la coopération
à cet égard est très intense vous savez
probablement que rosatom contribuer à la
création d'un centre de technologie
nucléaire au rwanda est aussi un centre
de médecine nucléaire
ces méthodes sont utilisés pour
diagnostiquer les maladies ce qui est
surtout important
cette période marquée par la pandémie
il est tout à fait évident que la
pandémie a modifié notre réalité et la
santé publique la sécurité alimentaire
les technologies les infrastructures
resteront les parmi les priorités pour
des années à venir a maintenant je tiens
à donner la parole aux membres du comité
et du compte c'est ou igor morosow
membres du comité pour la politique
économique du conseil de fédération de
russie
monsieur morozov tout d'abord je vous
demande de parler des activités
d'africom parce que cela est lié aussi
aux activités des régions russes et sur
le continent africain et en même temps
en tant que législateurs us
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans ce domaine quelles lois doivent
être adoptées pour donner un nouvel élan
cette coopération
merci à vous pour d'avoir posé c'est la
question de cette façon je voudrais
rappeler
simplement que le concept de la
fédération c'est à dire le sénat c'est
la chambre qui représente les régions
c'est à dire quant au représentant nos
85 région nous sommes en travail étroit
avec les entreprises et après le sommet
de sotchi en 2019 toutes les régions et
est prête à développer les axes de
coopération avec l'afrique et ce n'est
pas ça parce que pendant trente ans
pendant lesquels nous avons délaissé
cette raison et la concurrence est
installé et ce milieu concurrentiel est
complètement intégrée à la société
égyptienne à la législation égyptienne
et les conditions qu'ils qui se
présentent aujourd'hui pour les
entreprises russes ne sont pas tout à
fait celle qui existe pour les hommes
d'affaires de français ou d'europe ou
d'inde ou de chine et par conséquent le
le conseil de la fédération russe et
aussi la douma d'ailleurs j'ai un
collègue qui ici présents donc nous
devons établir une feuille de route qui
tienne compte de tous les changements
législatifs qui sont survenus et auquel
nous n'étions pas forcément attentif et
dont il ya des nouveaux fonctionnements
des nouveaux types de fonctionnement des
nouveaux mécanismes d'utilisation des
concessions par exemple dans les projets
d'investissement les rencontres
d'affaires par exemple la gestion des
monnaies nationales par exemple et nous
voyons que la transformation numérique
c'est si complètement l'afrique et
l'apparition par exemple d'une
électronique est un défi pour nous en
quelque sorte parce que aujourd'hui il
est manifeste que nos partenaires
chinois
un petit peu rod love you man
électronique sur la région africaine
donc nous espérons fortement que
l'apparition d'un trouble électronique
permettra ou en tout cas servira de
stimulant pour nos banques pour aller en
afrique et faire tout ce qui est
possible pour participer au financement
des start-up russo africaine aux
chambres de commerce russo africaine etc
et à la délocalisation d'entreprises
industrielles russe sur place donc il ya
une question qui se pose pour les
entreprises russes c'est à dire comment
nous allons financer la mise en place de
production sur place à travers quels
mécanismes et il ne faut aucun doute que
que le centre d'exportation russes ont
leur propre mécanisme mais les tables
rondes que nous organisons avec nos
entreprises régionales montre qu' il est
indispensable de créer un fonds un fonds
d'investissement un fonds
d'investissements directs pour est un
fou et un centre d'exportation russes
c'est important et cela manque parce que
nous sommes absolument convaincus que
quelles que soient les dispositions de
la loi au regard des concessions il ya
des risques qui se présente qui va les
supporter qui va effectuer l'évaluation
financière de ces concessions pour les
entreprises russes qui vont s'implanter
et donc il ya beaucoup de questions qui
apparaissent aujourd'hui
né autour du marché africain sont liées
à l'absence d'un fonds spécialisé et
nous voyons nos partenaires de chine
d'inde et de l'union européenne
utilisez justement ce mécanisme de
financement et c'est un point très
important pour nos entreprises
régionales
et je pense que avec la douma nous
allons travailler sur ce sujet avec les
représentants des entreprises avec le
centre d'exportation
j'aurais parlé aussi des modèles qui
peuvent être utilisés pour cette
activité c'est la création de points
d'appui et dans les pays que nous
considérons comme prioritaires
et ça pourrait être un modèle d'entrée
sur le marché ce sont des chambres de
commerce
ce sont des salons des expositions avec
le soutien du centre d'exportation de
russie ça peut être le soutien pour les
entreprises il va y en avoir une dans
quelques jours en ouganda par exemple
c'est à dire que il y a beaucoup de
d'entreprises qui sont interdits par
exemple de sibérie ce sont des
entreprises à haute technologie
ce sont des productions à haute
technologie qui sont déjà prêtes à
s'implanter en afrique
donc c'est un thème qui est très
important et mme adama bamba le voit
bien que vous faites décision mais je
vais finir mais je pense qu'il faut
réunir toutes les conditions nécessaires
pour soutenir les entreprises aux jeunes
et ça il faut le faire ensemble c'est à
dire créer une sorte d'organe qui gère
l'ensemble au niveau du ministère des
affaires étrangères au niveau des
entreprises du centre d'exportation de
russie au niveau des organes législatifs
de le conseil de la fédération à la
douma
parce que il faut bien un état major
général qui nous permette de réfléchir à
notre approche en afrique
merci monsieur morozov pour votre
évaluation de notre travail je pense que
nous devons réfléchir à toutes les
approches et tous les moyens
d'intensifier la coopération sur le
volet africain malheureusement le temps
est limité
je vous demande de ne pas dépasser 4 5
minutes parce que il ya beaucoup de
participants qui souhaitent s'exprimer
je donne la parole maintenant laragne
alma chatte le ministre égyptienne de la
coopération
madame la ministre nous savons tous que
l'egypte est notre partenaire clé en
afrique partenaire commercial jusqu'en
tiers de nos échanges avec l'afrique
sont effectués avec l'egypte il ya de
nombreux projets effectués en afrique en
egypte et les représentantes des
entreprises qui sont présentes ici qu'on
perd aussi avec l'egypte
la société égyptienne je sais qu'avant
vous avez occupé le poste du ministre du
tourisme nous savons que les échanges
dans ce domaine entre la russie et
l'egypte ont été très intenses e 6 e
je voudrais vous poser la question
suivante de vaud est aussi spécialiste
des relations financières qui elle est
votre vision des mécanismes de
coopération financière qui pourrait être
utile toi intensifier le développement
de notre coopération et je voudrais
également vous poser la question sur
l'avenir de la zone industrielle russe
en egypte
merci merci pour l'invitation à
participer à ce forum en présentiel
après 14 mois de la pandémie
cette occasion de 1 me réunir avec des
amis des collègues d'intervenir devant
le grand public et je tiens a invoqué
plusieurs moments l'air tout d'abord les
relations bilatérales entre l'egypte et
la russie est l'égypte est un pays
africain qui développe les programmes
d'investissement nous avons des projets
remarquables des projets communs avec la
russie par exemple aux stations
nucléaires des investissements de 1 13
milliard de dollars il s'agit aussi de
la coopération dans le domaine des
chemins de fer aussi long de libre
échange
aujourd'hui
nous avons discuté avec d'autres
ministres des possibilités de pouvoir la
coopération dans ces domaines
après le sommet à sotchi le président
égyptien avec le président poutine ont
souligné l'importance du rôle de
l'afrique dans ses relations dans le
développement de notre agenda et notre
toujours un autre moment important
malgré la pandémie nous avons des
possibilités de développer nos pays il y
à de nouvelles opportunités qui peuvent
être ouverts pour d'autres pays
notamment en matière d'investissements à
notre sujet important vous avez déjà
mentionné que l'egypte a fait beaucoup
pour développer le partenariat avec nos
voisins dans le monde des transports
nous développons des projets routiers
des projets de construction également
des entreprises privées des projets
d'irrigation et un autre aspect
important
nous invitons d'autres partenaires à
investir dans ces projets un autre sujet
important c'est la transformation
économique et politique qui sont encore
en egypte
nous avons vu que des secteurs qui se
transforme actuellement c'est tout
d'abord l'énergie
nous utilisons différent de systèmes de
transport de nettoyage
do i try to soul a été créée grâce à
notre expérience de coopération avec les
partenaires privés
les ppp sont maintenant un un
développement et moi je suis responsable
pour ces projets notre portefeuille et
de 20,4 milliards de dollars dans divers
secteurs de l'économie et de nombreux
projets sont des projets reconnus à
l'international par exemple le projet
dans le gabarit le projet caixa etc
il y à des programmes d'investissement
les investissements c'est un élément
important de notre coopération et compte
tenu de l'expérience que nous avons
accumulée et notamment dans nos projets
réussis nous pouvons résoudre d'autres
problèmes a joué le rôle clé sur le
continent africain
je tiens à souligner une fois encore et
que les accords de libre échange c'est
un aspect très important est la vision à
l'horizon 2060 3 cette stratégie est
élaborée par l'union européenne chaque
pays fait sa contribution il se focalise
sur la synergie entre le secteur privé
sur le continent elle les
investissements d'état et je pense que
les gouvernements doivent soutenions à
ces projets maintenant
on essaie d'éliminer les obstacles
bureaucratiques
ce qui permettra d'utiliser le potentiel
de notre continent dans son ensemble et
mettre en oeuvre nos projets nous nous
efforçons de d'accroître la coopération
avec la russie dans l'intérêt de
l'ensemble du continent
merci beaucoup madame la ministre vous
avez également un ancien et trois choses
importantes
tout d'abord vous avez mentionné l'agent
dale l'horizon 2060
3 je dis toujours que le succès de notre
coopération en russie afrique dépend
toujours de la prise en compte des
intérêts des africains mais les
objectifs inclus dans cet agenda il
s'agit des opportunités dont possède la
russie c'est très important à vous avez
également mentionné les ppp et c'est
dans ce pays aussi très important c'est
une condition nécessaire de notre
coopération
vous avez également parlé des projets
sociaux parce que l'afrique ce sont tout
d'abord les gens les africains et l'eau
qu'ils peuvent boire le la nourriture
qu'ils peuvent manger c'est très
important je veux votre citation sur les
l'enseignement pour les femmes pour les
filles c'est effectivement très
important je tiens à donner la parole à
alexandre saltanov un président de
l'association de coopération économique
avec les pays d'afrique mais ce saltanov
nous avons une image très
une très belle image de cette
coopération
mais je vous demande de parler des
problèmes qui existent qui doivent être
résolus dans le temps les années à venir
dans le cadre de coopération avec le
continent africain
parce que vous connaissez mieux que
personne ses problèmes l'association a
été créée il ya plus d'un an et vous
connaissez très bien auquel problème
notre business et confrontaient sur le
continent africain
merci je vous remercie je dirais pas que
la situation est si bonne que ça mon
collègue a soulevé la question du
soutien de l'état
donc notre campagne c'est évidemment de
d'assurer une avancée sur le continent
africain est donc l'idée d'un fonds
d'investissements directs dédié me
paraît tout à fait actuelle et je dirais
même que sans une telle solution à court
terme nos entreprises auront beaucoup de
difficultés à s'implanter à trouver des
débouchés sur un marché qui est déjà
fortement imprégné de concurrents
nous en avons parlé avec mon collègue
ici ces initiatives vent sont proposés
et je pense qu'effectivement il faut une
structure de deux fonds
d'investissements directs
il faut qu'elle soit développée dans le
cadre de notre à sensation et elle est
actuellement à l'examen dans les organes
de l'état mais
comme l'a dit mon collègue il faut unir
nos efforts travailler avec les
entreprises notamment celles qui font
partie de notre association il ya un
domaine important ici c'est
l'information et il faut dire
franchement ce que les problèmes sont
nombreux tant cette question parce que
dans les régions évidemment en tant qu à
six associations nous travaillons avec
les entreprises des régions et avec les
grandes entreprises aussi mais nous
savons bien ce qui se passe en afrique
quelles sont les perspectives qui
s'offent et je comprends bien que tout
cela est prometteur mais d'un autre côté
dans les pays africains
les gens connaissent la russie de façon
détournée
ils savent que ce n'est plus l'urss
m'enfin ils ont souvent une image
déformée de ce qu'est la russie
et donc ils se seraient particulièrement
utiles par exemple que rhj a tous des
ouvres un ou des bureaux dans des pays
africains de l'autre côté ce serait bien
qu'ils aient un échange d'informations
qui se fasse au niveau des entreprises
des marchés
et justement nous lançons ce travail
nous lançons donc un un projet d' espace
unifié d'informations entre la russie et
l'afrique pour développer les
investissements avec des chambres de
commerce gazprombank et la société
active data
nous espérons qu'au mois d'octobre nous
pourrons procéder à une démonstration
présentation complète de ce projet et
nous allons donc proposer un portail des
services de façon à assurer la promotion
de ses relations économiques et
commerciales entre la russie l'afrique
il ya encore un autre sujet qui me
paraît important aussi c'est
l'utilisation en fonction des réalités
nouvelles de l'expérience de l'époque
soviétique
c'est à dire que sous le format de
partenariat entreprise est à entreprises
on peut créer des entreprises de
commerce international qui coordonnerait
les efforts entre un pays concret ou une
région concrètes en afrique pour
collecter par exemple les les ans les
produits proposés par les entreprises
russes pour voir si on peut trouver un
débouché dans la région c'est à dire
qu'une entreprise tout seul peut pas
s'en sortir alors que si plusieurs
entreprises s'unissent dans un tel
projet ça accélérera le processus
j'ajouterai aussi que je voudrais
ajouter quelques mots sur l'enseignement
il y à quelques corrections apportées à
ce qui a été dit il ya un projet qui est
déjà lancé c'est une étude qui consiste
à savoir à identifier les besoins de nos
entreprises cadres africains c'est à
dire que ces africains pourraient
effectuer des stages ici suivre une
formation pour travailler là bas sur
place chez eux avec les technologies qui
seront proposés par notre côté par notre
parti
il ya encore une mission à laquelle nous
pouvons réfléchir et qui avait été
soulevé à une confiance que vous aviez
organisez-vous l'institut de l'afrique
c'est pour notre industrie pour notre
économie qu'est ce que nous pouvons
recevoir de l'afrique
c'était une question qui ce qui était
dans le passé qualifié de déquilibre
sectorielle mais qui aujourd'hui se pose
au niveau de l'état voilà en gros ce que
je voulais dire merci messieurs saltanov
une courte est question mais je me
réserve a parlé de la nécessité de créer
des centres dans plusieurs un pays aux
régions africain que pensez vous de
cette idée c est d est également proposé
au sommet russie afrique au cours d'une
session plénière dirigée par monsieur
shocking et il a évoqué la nécessité
cette nécessité
que pensez-vous de cdd de créer des
centres de représentation des
entreprises russes dans les régions clés
évidemment c'est une idée très juste
tout à fait il est plus simple de
travailler de travailler de façon
concentrée que les doigts de pieds
écartés et cherché dans tous les sens en
même temps donc à mon avis c'est tout à
fait réalisable
et si nous travaillons ensemble nous
devrions pouvoir y parvenir
merci beaucoup mais c'est un certain 9
et maintenant à notre chère invité nos
chers invités représentant dirigeants
des sociétés russes qui ont accumulé une
grande expérience de coopération avec le
continent africain
je tiens à donner la parole à carlipa
pdg de l'entreprise transmashholding un
monsieur lis pas je sais que vous avez
signé un grand contrat en des plus
grands contrats au sommet russie afrique
pour des livraisons des wagons des
voitures du train en egypte madame le
ministre est bien au courant de ce
contrat
mais vous avez aussi d'autres
expériences uniques par exemple vous
avez acheté une entreprise dans la ville
de boxe book où vous allez produire des
trains est est ce que vous êtes content
de se contracter sur les perspectives
pourquoi avez vous acheté cette usine
bien évidemment c'est très important
pour l'afrique de développer des projets
d'infrastructures est-ce que cela a été
liée à à ses intérêts est ce que vous
allez livrer peut-être vos produits dans
d'autres pays merci beaucoup de donner
la parole
évidemment effectivement cette
transaction qui est que nous avons menée
est exceptionnelle elle est unique parce
que le concerné les présidents de trois
pays
monsieur poutine monsieur sisi le
président égyptien est monsieur victor
ban le président hongrois et la banque
centrale de hongrie nous a accordé un
prêt de 20 milliards d'euros est de
cette façon la fabrication a été
organisée d'abord en russie avec 381 1
wagon mais en même temps parallèlement
nous développons et un site en hongrie
de production de 600 wagons qui vont
être livrés en egypte quand nous avons
traité de cette question avec le
président le 6 6 et madame le ministre
est au courant c'était à travers ce
projet d'établir des relations de
production industrielle avec un site
d'entretien du matériel de façon à
assurer la livraison de wagons dans
d'autres pays aussi
et donc c'est tout cela c'est une des
idées de ce projet justement avec une
structure que nous allons créer en blanc
créés sur place
si vous regardez l'afrique du sud vous
voyez aussi que si on regarde la carte
vous voyez que l'egypte est très
éloignée de l'afrique du sud
donc notre idée consiste à développer
deux plateformes au sud et au nord pour
les pays africains
l'entreprise se trouve à 70 km de
johannesburg nous l'avons lancée elle
fonctionne et dans le cadre du projet de
voitures passagers
on a déjà une production qui a été
lancée donc ce ne sont pas seulement des
motrices et des wagons mais aujourd'hui
nous produisons nous développons une
capacité industrielle et nous prévoyons
de
mené une coopération technologique
étroite entre les entreprises de russie
de hongrie et d'afrique
mais ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que
le développement de ce type d'activité
donc c'est pas seulement un
investissement en capital et en personne
bon au niveau du capital c'est clair
nous voyons que nous avons pu assurer un
financement pour la technologie vous
avez compris mais ce qui est important
c'est la communication entre les gens ce
que je veux dire c'est que nous avons
commencé à travailler en afrique du sud
pour nous début c'était un défi moi
c'était la première fois que j'étais là
bas et j'ai vu une culture très
similaire à ce qu'on a en russie
c'est des gens tout à fait ouverts très
direct et finalement qui nous
ressemblent beaucoup
en même temps qu'est ce que nous avons
fait nous avons procédé à une sorte
d'expérience
nous avons pris une 20h de soudeur une
partie d'entre eux c'étaient des femmes
l'autre des hommes nous avons envoyé
advair donc cette ville de russie à 100
150 km de moscou
ils ont subi ce suivi ce stage dont
parlait monsieur donc nous avons
commencé avec honnêtement une certaine
méfiance
c'était un grand défi pour dire quand
ils ont vu arriver au mois de décembre
ces gens venus d'afrique du sud
pour eux c'était évidemment un défi
aussi se retrouver en hiver en russie
mais je pense qu'ils ont reçu beaucoup
d'expérience et puis finalement beaucoup
de joie et je pense que la réputation de
notre entreprise et du pays en général
était fortement renforcée donc c'était
l'objet de discussions et ceux qui ont
participé à cette expérience ont été
très emballé
le deuxième exemple que je dois citer
qui est à mon avis tout à fait aussi
unique
il ya une conférence des brics et
parallèlement à cette à cette conférence
de brix ya eu donc une réunion des
milieux d'affaires de ces pays dans une
salle comme celle des six donc il y
avait des gens pareils qui était en
costume et cravate mais donc là l'allèle
la modératrice a commencé à chanter à la
fin imaginez que vous chantiez par
exemple katusha et bien croyez moi sacré
dans la salle une proximité
les gens se sont sentis beaucoup plus
libéré beaucoup plus ouvert pour
échanger entre eux et quand nous avons
inauguré une usine dont il y avait les
dirigeants provinciaux qui étaient là je
crois que c'est la deuxième ou la
première région d'afrique du sud il est
venu aussi en cravate nous étions tous
sans cravate
donc il ya eu des discours nous avons
parlé des plans et pareille avait une
chanteuse qui a une et après cette
animatrice a proposé que nous dansions
tous ensemble et c'était un choc pour
tout le monde mais moi même si j'aime
faire ça on va l'été est donc enfin vous
comprenez donc on était tous des adultes
mais on n'était pas habitué à danser sur
la scène et puis finalement on l'a fait
puisque apparemment ça faisait partie de
la tradition
et ça aussi souhaité encourager la
confiance le rapprochement entre les
gens entrent tous ceux qui ont participé
imaginer ici qu'à la fin de cette
réunion là tout le monde se mette à
hautmont branche la musique et tout le
monde se met à danser je pense que ce
serait pas évident pour tout le monde et
c
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya un
potentiel qui est énorme entre la russie
et l'afrique et l'afrique n'est pas une
exception
face à toutes les tendances qu'on voit
dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est
l'urbanisation l'augmentation de la
population ces développements des
technologies c'est le développement de
l'accès aux transports
c'est la construction de structures
porteuses infrastructures portuaires et
la russie dispose de toutes les
compétences et technologies nécessaires
pour comme j'ai entendu dire ce qui est
un peu dommage c'est de revenir après de
longues années perdues voilà c'est ça
que je veux dire je vous remercie
merci mais se lit pas ce serait un grand
plaisir pour moi de chanter à la fin de
cette réunion mais votre discours a été
assez long donc malheureusement je ne
vais pas chanter mais la prochaine fois
on va tous chantés et dansés je pense
que c'est une bonne idée que la coupe là
la coopération humaine est très
important est favorable il faudrait dans
son ensemble maintenant je voudrais
donner la parole à monsieur pavlov qui
représente une grande entreprise
les chemins de fer le russe
monsieur pavlov je sais que vous avez
signé au sommet
des contrats avec quatre pays africain
l'egypte le la république démocratique
du congo l'angola et à notre pays et je
sais que vous avez des projets comment
avec ces pays et dans l'optique de cet
agenda à l'horizon 2060 3 c'est très
important de développer les chemins de
fer sur le continent africain
selon vous quelle est la situation
actuelle avec ces quatre projets que je
viens de mentionner et la russie est
notamment liée chemins de fer russes et
quelle est leur position sur le
développement dans ce domaine sur le
continent africain
le représentant de transmashholding à
quoi que des perspectives sont très
considérable mais quels sont vos projets
est ce que vous coopérez avec la société
transmashholding parce que souvent les
entreprises ne coopèrent pas mais quelle
est la situation entre vos deux sociétés
et que pensez vous de la stratégie
générale des chemins de fer russes
s'agissait plutôt de grands projets ou
est-ce qu'il est plus important de se
focaliser sur des projets régionaux
merci beaucoup et au nom de notre
entreprise
les chemins de fer de russie je voudrais
vous remercier de m'avoir accordé la
possibilité de m'exprimer ici et je vous
remercie aussi rose congress d'avoir
organisé ces d'avoir proposé cette
possibilité de
discuter pour répondre à votre question
sur le lien avec transmashholding
évidemment nous travaillons toujours
ensemble on l'a toujours fait on le fait
et on va le faire parce que ces
entreprises sont leaders sur ce marché
et on est obligé de toute façon de
travailler ensemble il ya un exemple
concret c'est l'égypte donc justement le
gîte à commencer par ce projet avec
transmashholding qui a été élaborée à
partir de 2009 et une fois qu'il a été
lancé et nous comme roddick
nous avons compris que avec ce
producteur de matériel roulant où il
fallait que nous travaillons ensemble
parce que livrer des trains des wagons
et le faire sans infrastructures ça va
pas donc nous avons commencé et nous
continuons à le faire nous avons au
ministre des transports au ministre
égyptien des transports nous avons
adressé un plan de restructuration de
reconstruction de réaménagement du
réseau ferroviaire et dans l'ensemble
les chemins de fer russes considèrent
que l'afrique est un marché avec des
débouchés particulièrement riche
c'est un continent très important et
tous les pays du continent ont tous les
indicateurs économiques nécessaires pour
assurer ce développement cette dynamique
à condition d'utiliser de développer
justement le réseau de transport c'est
une des conditions importantes du point
de vue économique et rgd des chemins de
fer russes peuvent justement présenter
l'ensemble des services nécessaires à
cela mais il s'agit vraiment ici de
développer le système de transport nous
avons
et solution tout à fait de pointe au
niveau mondial en matière d'organisation
de mouvement des trains la gestion des
matériels roulants la gestion des
systèmes de communication et de
transmission de données et quand nous
considérons l'afrique et grâce à notre
travail avec transmashholding
nous estimons que l'egypte justement
sera le point de départ qui nous
permettra de travailler avec d'autres
pays et madame la ministre l'a dit ça
veut dire que même chez eux au niveau
politique il ya cette volonté d'utiliser
le pays comme un couloir d'accès aux
autres pays africains et l'egypte
elle-même a fait beaucoup en la matière
donc pour cette raison nous voulons
continuer à travailler ensemble dans
cette voie nous avons d'autres
perspectives intéressantes entend année
et comme le lady en marche du sommet
russie afrique nous avons discuté avec
le président tanzanien et nous avons
décidé de travailler ensemble
malheureusement la pandémie a altéré ses
liens mais dès que la situation le
permettra
nous reprendrons ses contacts et nous
irons dans ce pays pour discuter et
mettre en place un dialogue concret le
ghana le botswana le maroc sont des pays
qui offrent des opportunités pour nous
et nous pensions que nous pourrions
travailler dans ces pays
quant aux projets que nous avons signés
lors du sommet russie afrique en 2019 la
situation
à évoluer certains projets
ont été annulés le monde évolue la chaux
graff y évoluent nous avons beaucoup
parlé du modèle de concession et je
pense que ce modèle peut être examiné
dans la mesure où il nécessite un
investissement important à l'étape
initiale
mais justement précisément en afrique
pour se développer rapidement à forte
dynamique il faut justement utiliser ces
modèles de concessions mais de façon ce
qui est des garanties de la part de
l'état pour que l'investisseur se
sentent protégés et qu'ils aient une
réduction des risques dans notre pays la
situation est rendue plus compliquée
dans la mesure où nos institutions
[Musique]
organisations financières ont des
limites assez étroite pour travailler en
afrique
vous comprenez bien que quand on lance
un projet ferroviaire il nous faut une
marche de risque importante avec des
investissements conséquents
donc il faut que les investisseurs
russes puissent travailler avec eux les
investisseurs locaux
ici dans le cadre du forum de saint
pétersbourg nous avons parlé avec le
viseur de afrexim bank et nous avons
discuté des étapes suivantes
nous allons parler c'est bien maintenant
il faut passer aux actes
2 alors allez-y ouvert on voit se rend
compte en va discuter et on va choisir
concrètement un projet pour commencer à
travailler dessus
est ce le résultat que nous devons viser
et atteindre tous ensemble compte tenu
que le temps est limité
pour résumer je voudrais dire que pour
résoudre pour parvenir à cet objectif
qui est celui de tous les pays africains
aujourd'hui il est évident que rgd est
intéressé est prêt à dispose de toutes
les compétences pour proposer un des
systèmes de transport les plus modernes
les plus à la pointe et en participant
avec le soutien des organismes
financiers
je vous remercie
le chef de l'état est présent ici et je
vais
oui donnez la parole parce que c'était
un sujet très important le financement
de projets en afrique
c'est un grand sujet merci de m'avoir
parlé il faut effectivement modifié les
approches des concessions il faut
discuter du développement
cet égard pour que les concessions
puisse fonctionner à part entière et
maintenant je tiens à donner la parole à
dmitry coignard président du conseil
d'administration de dürer chaîne groupe
nous avons parlé aujourd'hui des
difficultés entraînées par la pandémie
et difficulté pour nous pour nous et
pour le continent africain
mais il ya aussi de nouvelles
opportunités pour l'afrique la question
de la sécurité alimentaire est une des
questions clés et votre société
contribue beaucoup à la résolution de ce
problème
merci madame abramova merci pour cette
possibilité de participer à ce forum si
représentatif
permettez moi comme les regardons
objectivement en 2050 la population de
l'afrique aura doublé ce sera 2 milliard
et demi d'habitants
aujourd'hui l'afrique ce c'est 15% de la
population de la planète est elle sera
sont là 25%
en même temps il faut comprendre que en
afrique et il y à la question grave qui
se pose de la sécurité alimentaire et la
ration moyenne de l'africain se trouve
c'est 1800 calories alors que la norme
est normalement c'est 3500 surtout si on
regarde la zone subsaharienne y ait des
opportunités gigantesque qui se
proposent pour l'agriculture on peut
faire trois ou quatre mois son parent on
peut culte faire des cultures techniques
et en même temps l'afrique est
importatrice de biens alimentaires sur
fond de l'augmentation de la population
alors quels sont les problèmes les
problèmes sont habituelles c'est à dire
que l'agriculture est mené de façon
traditionnelle avec des méthodes
traditionnelles et que le niveau de
mécanisation et
d'utilisation d'engrais se trouve à un
niveau très bas en afrique il ya en gros
ce 17 kg d'engrais utilisé par hectare
ces dix ou quinze fois moins que ce qui
est utilisé dans les pays industrialisés
oui nous livrons des engrais en afrique
chaque année nous doublons le volume des
livraisons mais c'est comme une activité
commerciale de deux traits dire qui est
difficile parce que vous trouvez des
clients qui ont des capacités de
paiement et qui toutes façons ne résout
pas le problème
pour résoudre ce problème il faut
probablement utilisé et d'examiner deux
questions la première c'est la
délocalisation c'est à dire
l'installation sur place de production
parce que en afrique il ya suffisamment
de ressources pour cela il ya le gaz
pour la production pour les engrais
azotés
il ya des gisements de phosphates et
dans cette voie nous avons deux projets
là en angola l'autre en mozambique 2
avançons lentement pour l'instant et je
dirais que pour l'instant si on en est
encore au niveau des études et de
l'élaboration des plans ça ce premier
point
le deuxième point c'est que sur le
continent africain
nous devons être présents pas seulement
sur le plan de grosses livraisons par
exemple au gros son volant mais aussi au
niveau des canaux de distribution les
collègues l'ont dit avant moi le
problème en afrique il énorme
et il ya toujours le problème du
kilomètre d'or c'est à dire l'accès et
cela concerne les anglais c'est à dire
qu il faut aussi former les gens pour
qu'ils apprennent à s'en servir
ici il faut à la fois combinés les
objectifs et les moyens il faut des
canaux de distribution et en même temps
il faut investir et notamment veste
investir en formation des fermiers et
nous les entreprises nous regardons pas
ça du point de vue de des actions de
bienfaisance ou caritatives et au lieu
de chercher à concurrencer jusqu'au
dernier dollar dans un marché à hauteur
hautement concurrentiel il faut chercher
là où il ya un avenir
là où il ya des opportunités et ces
marchés il faut les créer il s'agit pas
de confier il s'agit simplement de les
créer mais je pense que le jeu en vaut
la chandelle
et donc c'est une orientation ici que
nous voulons développer en afrique c'est
la numérisation il de l'agriculture
c'est à dire mettre en place des
plateformes de numériser la numérisation
et que nous utilisons déjà bien en
russie mais qui peuvent être appliqués
dans en afrique il ya déjà beaucoup de
startups en afrique qui ont besoin
d'être soutenus
on peut importer l'expérience des
start-up indienne où on a des petites
fermes qui travaille très bien
c'est à dire que si je le chiffre je
vais pas forcément très important ici
mais ça veut dire que le chiffre pour
nous c'est simplement un accélérateur
ce qui gêne et si c'est quoi il y à des
freins ici première chose c'est qu'il
nous faut un soutien de l'état et ce
soutien de la part de l'état doit se
faire dans différentes orientations au
niveau des garanties au niveau du
financement et permettez moi je vais
peut-être me répéter parce que
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont déjà
été dites mais je dirais qu'il ya trois
points importants où on a vraiment
besoin d'un appui de l'état n'a pu des
institutions de l'état la première chose
c'est que la russie au niveau national
et des grandes entreprises peut créer un
centre d'investissement de développement
ça peut être un fond c'est peut être la
chance de garantie d'exportation
d'amendé d'investissement avec des taux
directeurs qui peuvent être choisis ici
pour la mise en place de 5 le deuxième
point c'est que les contrats ne sont pas
toujours signé avec tous les pays
africains et les accords il ya souvent
des accords de double de double
imposition et qu'il faut revoir et je
pense que là où il n'y a pas encore de
d'investisseurs intéressés il faut
réfléchir troisième point c'est établir
des contacts directs entre les
entreprises des deux pays et donc il ya
des commission intergouvernementale qui
peuvent être mises en place et aider à
organiser des visites réciproques et
nous en tant que grande entreprise nous
sommes prêts à participer à tous les
programmes de l'état et nous nous sommes
souvent d'ailleurs des guides et et des
aides pour ces deux d'entre eux mais
j'espère que les autorités de la
fédération de russie nous entendrons et
soutiendront ces initiatives
je vous remercie merci koné yeves dans
la salle il y a quatre personnes qu'elle
est je voudrais également donné la
parole parce que le peuvent
ils sont capables de répondre aux
questions qui ont été posées
tout d'abord je tiens à donner la parole
à une kitab oussakov pdg de la société
sk
c'est une agence russe d'assurance des
crédits et l'exportation monsieur goût
sackhoff a tout d'abord quelle est votre
réaction aux propositions qui ont été
faites aujourd'hui
et puis je voudrais vous poser une
question concernant les le volume de 5
milliards de dollars de cette plateforme
évoqué pendant le sommet russie afrique
qui visait à résoudre en nombre de
problèmes pour attirer les
investissements en afrique et
intensifier les échanges commerciaux
entre la russie et l'afrique
quel serait votre commentaire mais c'est
vous cher collègue les entrailles merci
effectivement la question
les questions étaient justement poser
ici et nous devons constituer l'année
passée depuis un an et demi qui sont
passés depuis le sommet
nous n'avons pas fait tout ce que j'ai
prévu je pense que c'est partiellement
liée à la pandémie qui a limité les
déplacements et les contacts physiques
entre les pays mais objectivement le
problème clé et
qui a déjà été soulevé c'est le manque
de connaissances et de possibilité
d'être reconnus nous n'y connaissons peu
les entreprises russes connaissent peu
des spécificités du marché africain les
particularités de ce marché et les
entreprises africaines connaissent peu
les produits russes et c'est ça qui nous
empêche concrètement de conclure des
affaires et nous avons tout un programme
de développement des entreprises de
promotion et malheureusement nous
n'avons pu le réaliser que partiellement
nous avons eu deux trois missions en
ligne qui ont été faites et
malheureusement c'est quand même pas la
même chose que quand il ya des
rencontres physiques pour des
entreprises par exemple
donc nous avions un plan de
participation à des expositions qui
devait avoir lieu en afrique et qui ont
dû être annulées et reportées
nous espérons qu'elles auront lieu et
que l'année prochaine tout cela se fera
c'était que le problème aujourd'hui pas
tellement problèmes de financement mais
surtout le manque de connaissances
suffisantes et de contacts c'est à dire
que les succès que nous avons déjà eu
que les entreprises ont déjà obtenu et
qui ont été évoqués ici à cette session
et je pense que c'est bien et que nous
ayons en parler aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que nous malgré les risques
la nécessité de restructurer nous sommes
prêts à participer avec notre partenaire
afrexim bank pour mettre en place un 1-1
outils de soutien ici à ces projets
c'est donc c'est pas de temps preuve de
financement que de projets concrets
le deuxième point que dmitry connaît
enfin soulever c'est que ça manque de
régulation dans certains pays et quand
on fait de d'investissement
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
signés dont il n'y a pas de possibilité
de garantir tout cela et cela est un
obstacle pour les entreprises russes
pour trouver des débouchés sur le marché
africain et donc nous devons travailler
aussi avec le ministère des affaires
étrangères ici donc tu as une plateforme
qui a été annoncé effectivement et nous
avons deux transactions en discussions
aujourd'hui et que nous allons essayer
de développer pour l'instant sur des
volumes très bas c'est à dire au niveau
de 55 millions de dollars
mais nous avons bon appétit et nous
avons des discussions avec des banques
commerciales demande commerciale russe
qui sont prêtes à assurer à proposer des
assurances crédit mais la question pas
tellement une preuve de ressource mais
justement des des projets et encore un
point c'est le le financement de
l'actionnariat des schémas de
financement qui ont été proposées nous
ne pouvons proposer mais les entreprises
russes qui investissent sur le continent
africain ont besoin de partenaires en
local mais aussi d'un soutien
institutionnel et la l'initiative qui
est discutée actuellement sur la
création d'un fonds
je comprends que c'est risqué pour
l'état mais en même temps c'est
important parce que c'est ça qui peut
avoir un effet multiplicateur dans
l'orientation que nous choisissons je
vous remercie
merci monsieur goose accord je donne la
parole ou directeur de la relation
client chez l'afreximbank acquis et
allant des grands partenaires du centre
d'exportation russes
à vous la parole
merci irina un premier point je dois
dire que la banque d'exportations
africaines est d'abord je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité à participer à cette
session est de parler de dialogue russo
africains parce que vous savez que comme
institution financière majeure en
afrique nous proposons s'attendre de
service nous soutenons les entreprises
russes en 2010 est par exemple nous
avons signé un accord avec le centre
d'exportation et pour que les
entreprises fassent partie de notre
capital africains et qu'elle participe à
nous à nos flux commerciaux il ya ici
plusieurs milliards de dollars qui ont
été et ça devrait on devrait pas revenir
à 40 milliards ces prochaines années
nous avons participé avec différentes
entreprises dans différents domaines
nous avons conclu des contrats avec
différentes entreprises pour soutenir
les échanges
nous soutenons aussi nous travaillons
aussi avec des entreprises comme un sous
chrome mais aussi les chemins de fer de
russie
nous avons nous allons mener des
rencontres au mois de juillet au niveau
de la coopération et nous examinons
d'autres projets d'investissement ici
par exemple transmash holding sur une
production de locomotives de motrice en
matière de cybersécurité de de commerce
de d'agriculture et donc il ya des
entreprises d'investissement qui
viennent ça veut dire que nous sommes
sur le bon sur le bon chemin
mais quand on parle de problèmes de
financement on voit qu'il ya un fossé
entre la russie et l'afrique
cette info tu es un fossé médiatique
il ya un manque d'information de il faut
qu'ils aient un bureau d'information qui
permettent de donner un éclairage sur ce
que propose l'afrique et nous
travaillons aussi à organiser des
missions commerciales pour faire venir
les entreprises ou de russie et comme
l'a dit le directeur du bureau de du
centre d'exportation de russie nous
avons eu des rencontres en ligne
donc nous allons l'année prochaine aussi
organisé un forum comme je le disais je
le déjà dit sera la suite du sommet
comme il avait été fait à en 2019 à
sotchi je pense que ce sera la suite
mais en afrique et la réussit un
excellent partenaire et tous ceux qui
sont présents ici aujourd'hui en sont
convaincus et nous apprécions votre
contribution dans le succès du continent
africain et c'est grâce à du reste que
nous avons accédé à la halle à
l'indépendance et donc nous voulons
continuer à travailler avec la russie
nous a besoin d'un soutien humanitaire
et de mettre en place des relations qui
soit bénéfique pour tous je vous
remercie
merci monsieur wang
maintenant je donne la parole à joshua
c'est y pas le directeur exécutif de la
banque des technologies pour le pied le
mois
avancer votre banque c'est la banque des
technologies nous avons déjà parlé avec
lou du développement de la coopération
technologique entre la russie et les
pays africains
vous travaillez sur la promotion des
technologies dans les piles les moins
avancés du monde et plus de 30 pile
moins avancés parmi les 46 se trouvent
en afrique et y est il des projets avec
la participation des sociétés russes en
afrique
s'agit-il du transfert des technologies
russes en afrique auxquels votre banque
des technologies à participer merci
beaucoup je voudrais répondre à votre
question
un site en deux
fait important vous avez dit que entre
la russie et l'afrique il n'ya plus que
que
coopération plus qu'un commerce
il s'agit ici d'une diplomatie
scientifique ce que nous faisons c'est
de créer de nouvelles capacités pour
pouvoir mener une politique de
coopération technologique
tout d'abord il s'agit de créer une
économie ou des connaissances notre
territoire devient le territoire de la
science et des connaissances
nous avons mis en place des centres aux
maladies à un goal à shadows et dans
d'autres pays ce qui nous permet de
contribuer à la promotion de la science
et de la diplomatie scientifique
c'est ainsi que les pays africains
développe et renforce leur capacité
peuvent coopérer avec la communauté
internationale scientifique
je suis convaincu que les partenariats
avec des instituts tels que le vôtre
serait très intéressant pour vous et
pour nous un autre aspect c est le
manque de connaissance
certaines entreprises ne comprennent pas
les process les processus qui se déroule
sur le continent depuis que notre banque
été créé nous menons analyse pour aider
les pays à mettre en oeuvre à ses
projets dans les domaines clés nous
fixons des priorités pour chaque pays et
aujourd'hui et léa 14 projets de ce type
on m'a la vie à luanda le ce taux est
ainsi on peut définir les domaines
prioritaires pour chaque pays
mais il s'agit non seulement
et d'opportunités sur le marché nos
missions de créer de nouvelles capacités
parce que nous savons que le potentiel
d'investissement en afrique un énorme
vous pouvez venir dans des feuilles et
africains pour le voir nous sommes en
faveur du transfert des technologies
nous croyons que cette plateforme
c'est une discussion c'est une
possibilité de transférer l'expérience
russe
si on examine par exemple le domaine de
finitec finances technologies on peut
aussi utiliser cette expérience
voilà à quoi ce partenariat peut servir
à nous sommes très ravis d'être ici et
participer à ces discussions
merci pour votre discours désolé nous ne
pouvons pas finir je ne voudrais pas
interrompre non participants parce que
le sujet est très important et je tiens
donner la parole à monsieur l'excité pas
vice président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la douma
un monsieur tu sais pas pourriez vous
parler s'il vous plaît de cette
plateforme d'investissement en russie
afrique qui ont été créées récemment je
vous remercie
mesdames messieurs c'est plus de 30 ans
d'expérience
le travail avec les pays africains et je
travaille aujourd'hui avec l'afrique
dans le cadre de la commission de
l'afrique du douma de la douma nous
avons des discussions tout à fait
intéressante et tous les participants
aujourd'hui on parlait de l'intérêt
des pays africains entre la russie et
l'afrique
et le résultat c'est que on a une
augmentation du volume des échanges
entre nos pays la coopération dans le
domaine commercial un arrêt des
investissements ne cesse d'augmenter et
bien entendu dans le domaine des
services et des technologies cette
coopération ne cesse de croître
il ya un grand besoin de créer des
instruments d'investissement c'est ce
que presque tous les intervenants dit
aujourd'hui c'est important de pouvoir
réagir rapidement aux différents défis
qui se proposent et être capable
d'investir rapidement et d'où la douma
comme ça a été dit par certains des
partenaires
ici nous sommes heureux de proposer à
votre attention
un nouveau produit innovant que nous
avons reçues en matière de relations
entre les pays au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
nouvelles technologies entre la russie
l'afrique et ce projet peut permettre
d'agir de coopérer de façon tout à fait
positive dans le cadre de l'axé de
l'action russo africaine dirigée par
monsieur saldana cela fait partie d'un
des mécanismes dont a parlé mon collègue
igor morosow cette plateforme
cette plateforme
est un outil qui permet de trouver très
rapidement des informations précises qui
peuvent concerner toutes les entreprises
sur les secteurs sur les produits etc
dan hesse elle permet d'analyser les
prospections des entreprises et
d'identifier des partenaires
autrement dit cette plateforme donne une
analyse complète du marché des
entreprises et propose un tout une
panoplie d'outils qui permettent de
conclure des transactions sous format
électronique c'est très pratique et cela
se fait peut-être fait sûrs en six
langues il ya un point important c'est
que cette plateforme propose une forme
électronique des documents sans sans
avoir besoin de recourir au support par
terre un paquet et nous pouvons utiliser
la signature électronique pour en
conformité avec la législation conclure
des transactions travailler avec
l'ensemble des documents officiels
nécessaires et tout cela tous ces
documents ont toujours leur force
juridique qui peut être tout à fait
contraire contesté dans les deux
tribunaux internationaux barre grâce à
ces outils
cela permet de faire disparaître les
disparités les inégalités et le
lancement de la plateforme
d'investissement est prévue pour 2022
c'est à dire pour l'ouverture du
deuxième sommet russie afrique
mais dès maintenant nous sommes prêts à
adresser sous forme électronique un lien
à la vidéo de présentation de cette
plateforme je pense que ça pourrait être
intéressant pour vous j'en suis
convaincu je vous remercie
merci monsieur je sais pas voudrait
donner la parole à son excellence
monsieur vital al enezi wisser président
du parlement de la république
démocratique du congo congo officiel
strana pour beaucoup de nos fréquences
continuer ce projet nous sommes certes
sa fréquence qui va continuer lâche
prise et diane félix tshisekedi cats
auraient dit si vous ne votez pas si job
racing n'a crié très fort beau gabarit
net est fort aussi pour cela que je
crache au portillon hospitalier
le président à la présidente à vis des
six camarades sur l'excellence feel that
one qui s'équipent isa l'est de donno
avoué de riga xinjiang est un geste
betnet informatique sachs ou au mexique
at all blacks à magistrat qu'à tort
comme adeline à mme bahrami candidat
vous la connaissez dire qu'à chaque
ouvrier aux uns et autres bagatelles
strana à grands pas
stratégie que nous les avons obéi on a
six bagatelles à passo di lota le cobalt
une parodie on a grommelé brefs délais
sauf à l'équilibré tellement présent
notre écosystème
le nouveau manga barça
eminem qui me tanne hannachi poignet
cassé ce groupe mythique et le congo à
sa groupe et une salle de la présence
trois guides rennais richesse activement
et vos données pour tim duncan est la
chine et céline starlette parade
costumée l'aumône aux forges itélé est à
gros mais très vite les quatorze
intéressant en revenant aux sources et
14 étapes gillett s'est rabattu sur 14
mois je prédis de serviès 30-14
chrétienne a freiné le présent leur
équipe n'est pas restée présidente
républicaine pour améliorer le jep
révélé à kronach aboiteaux power chen
haosu à vide et appartenait steve nash
et règne
prokhorov qui est d'agir touristique
européen pour la énième business que les
moteurs et non reconduit ce titre i pass
magnin achevant président y est d'abord
apparaître comme une chasse et la
cueillette chapeau messieurs merci votre
excellence 1 la république démocratique
du congo est actuellement le président
de l'union africaine je pense que c'est
une grande opportunité pour nos
relations bilatérales
merci à toutes et à tous
je peux dire que la russie a besoin de
l'afrique et l'afrique a besoin de
russie sans ce continent africain ce
jeune continent la russie ne pourra pas
accomplir ses tâches et étendre
augmenter les exportations de l'afrique
est un partenaire important pour notre
pays il faut penser toujours au chaud
suivante
les ppp les centres régionaux de soutien
aux entreprises la coopération dans le
domaine des technologies la mise en
place de nouvelles législations assez
des gares et la formation des
spécialistes des experts la
communication humaine est également très
importante pour notre coopération
je tiens à remercier tous les
participants et j'espère que nous sommes
au début de cette voie de coopération et
de développement de notre amitié
merci